explications avec michel lisez
économistes retraité du service aux
collectivités de l'icam de l'uqam
bonsoir monsieur lisez françois fillon
une assurance rente comme il est proposé
et comme on connaît en ontario est ce
que c'est une bonne idée en soi c'est
une bonne idée
le problème c'est dans le contexte
actuel un tel fonds ne sera probable
parce qu'essentiellement contrairement à
la situation de l'ontario ou quand leurs
fonds ont été mis sur pied les régimes à
prestations déterminées il y en avait
beaucoup il est en croissance
il était en bonne finition financière
comme si les caisses de retraite qui
doivent financer le fond il y avait pas
de problème aujourd'hui on la part dans
une situation où les régimes à
prestations déterminées sont en déclin
en 2016
en 2002 il y en avait plus de 800 2016
10 ans restaient 657 mais là dessus en
960 qui sont fermées de nouveaux
participants qui sont virtuellement
terminée et le nombre de 16 pc et vous
allez demander à 400 caisses de retraite
de financer un fonds pour couvrir des
déficits problème ça représenterait pas
vraiment à une li % de pourcin vue à vue
d'oeil de l'actif de chaque régime par
année ça ferait juste une raison de plus
pour laquelle les employeurs qui
continuent à sortir massivement des
régimes à prestations déterminées le
fallait il ya une condition selon
laquelle le fonds serait viable s'il
était associé à la notion que le
gouvernement garantit ce fonds là est
donc un code de manque d'argent le
grognement seraient tenus de combler le
manque à gagner pour verser les montants
oui on parle beaucoup de fonds de
l'ontario il faut pas oublier qu'à
certaines périodes
ce fonds là a été à sec et il est
vraiment de l'ontario a dû lui avancer
de l'argent sauf forme de prêt soit sous
forme de subventions ou qu'il passe au
travers
puis dans d'autres pays comme les etats
unis le royaume uni leurs fonds sont
absents pratique insolvables ou à où ils
vont bientôt cesser de verser des aides
mais est ce que le système ontarien même
avec l'intervention occasionnel du
gouvernement n'est pas la preuve que ce
système ne peut fonctionner il pourrait
fonctionner mais il faut bien comprendre
que si vous avez des régimes à
prestations déterminées qui sont déjà en
mauvaise situation finances
ah et le financement dépend de votre
situation financière s'il ya un nombre
de plus en plus petits
c'est écrit dans le ciel que ce bassin
l'eau ne sera pas capable de financer la
charge parce que chaque année moins de
caisses de retraite une situation
financière plus difficile des charges
accrues une spirale qui vont
essentiellement entraînés les employeurs
à le faire et le gouvernement québécois
risque de leur donner la porte de sortie
dans quelques mois
il va proposer une loi sur les régimes à
prestations aux cibles qui devrait
inclure la possibilité pour un employeur
de convertir le régime à prestations
déterminées qui l'a en régime à
prestation aux cibles où ça n'existe
plus la notion d'une rente garantie
alors ça va changer quoi ça encore moins
deux régimes qui vont financer le fonds
est donc la perspective pour les
retraités dont l'entreprise fait
faillite de recevoir une rente garantie
ne sera plus là parce qu'ils sont déjà
rendus dans un autre type de régime est
entre-temps le fonds va s'avérer de plus
en plus fragile donc je vous écoute là
j'ai l'impression que la proposition de
ce matin d'abord ne sera pas adoptée le
ministre a été très clair mais mais
c'est même pas une bonne solution pour
régler les problèmes qu'on veut riquet
sauve comme je le dis s'il y avait une
garantie publique mais politiquement les
chances de ce sont plus faibles
ouais mais ça prend des solutions parce
qu'il se fait des années qu'on s'empare
de ces régimes de retraite où il ya des
entreprises qui se retrouvent sous la
protection des tribunaux ou en faillite
et l'oeil pouf il ya 30% de moins et on
en parlait à l'époque de nortel à 10 km
et qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve comme bonne
solution d'une pareille faute et que
l'ontario dont on parle souvent
contrairement au gouvernement du québec
en 2015 ne pas abolir l'obligation de
financer le déficit de solvabilité alors
qu'au québec c'est tomber donc depuis
on a accru la vulnérabilité des
retraités encore essayée ici parce que l
emploi n'est plus tenue de financiers de
ces de solvabilité en ontario il s'en
suit quelques années a accepté l'idée
mais seulement si la solvabilité
supérieur à 85% dès qu'elle est en bord
l'employeur doit se remettre à
refinancer les régions pour l'année au
moins 85% pour éviter les pires cas
d'une faillite avec des pertes de 25 30
35 % donc déjà l'ontario montre une
piste
qui pourrait être regardé à plus long
terme ma conviction c'est que ça prend
un renforcement des règles de
financement de ces régimes là pour quand
même leur actif ils puissent supporter
les rangs des retraités en cas de
faillite
l'idée d'une réserve importante saute
aux yeux comme piste une réserve financé
par par une cotisation additionnelle
dans le code rrfs qui est l'exemple qui
existent tout ça ça se fait actuellement
c'est que la cotisation versée de votre
récent 50 % de la cotisation requise à
ce que l'excédent finance une réserve
pour l'indexation donc qui finance les
négociations c'est pas la même chose que
l'assurance en ontario d'assurance rente
non pas du tout c'est l'argent et dans
la caisse
elle sert à la fois financer des rentes
de retraite mais en cas de faillite
comme elle dispose d'une réserve elle eu
beaucoup plus d'argent pour financer les
rentes des retraités donc l'heureuse une
coupure importante et beaucoup plus
ferme et juste bien comprendre qu'ils
financent la réserve
les cotisations des employeurs et des
employés à la caisse de retraite et donc
ça ça serait une solution qu'on pourrait
adopter
sauf que nac ma crainte c'est que les
employeurs ne veulent pas de cette
solution là parce que ce qu'ils veulent
c'est se sortir des régimes à
prestations déterminées de cours ou
aller vers des cotisations déterminées à
les défaire des prestations cède ou des
prestations à la prestation cep sa
cotisation est fixe et en côte du site
c'est les rentes des retraités ou des
actifs qui sont crus
puis en cas de faillite la notion de non
garantie n'existe plus
donc c'est la seule option c'est
pourquoi les employeurs veulent
tellement de cette option là alors
qu'ils ne veulent pas des erreurs et fès
qui pourtant leur fausser une rente
garantie si le régime de retraite un
financement car elle ne permet pas de le
convertir
ils doivent quand on s'en va vers de
moins en moins de garanties pour les
retraités c'est ce que vous nous dites
dans le fond du côté des régimes à
prestations déterminées
la proposition actuelle est peut-être
trop peu trop tard alger répète si il y
avait une garantie publique d'attaché as
a way
là il serait viable mais le gouvernement
comprend le reste de ce que je viens de
vous expliquer qui comprend bien qu'ils
tentaient de se mettre la main dans le
tordeur de façon croissante au fil des
ans bien monsieur lisez merci pour cette
explication ce soir ça va tenir c'est
beaucoup